when I write a character that doesn't
have a lot that doesn't say a lot
doesn't get it across a lot in uh in
dialogue and doesn't have that many
story beats I tend to write those
characters more prose like
I tend to write them a little bit more
like a novel all right uh uh you know
and I'm I'm putting a lot of stuff in
there that you guys the audience is
never gonna see and you're never
supposed to see it all right but it's
it's there for the reader
you know I want the person who's reading
the script to have a good time and to be
engaged in the story and there's stuff
for the reader that's meant for them and
and and it's not meant for you but it's
also it's meant for the actor
and so it gives the actor like a sense
of who this guy is all right in the case
of uh uh describing
Rick Dalton's career for example I wrote
that as not just like a chapter in a
book I wrote it like a chapter of a film
book like a film book about Rick Dalton
it was when Leo read that is what
finally pushed him over the edge to say